president trump is still not saying
whether he will sign the latest 900
billion
coronis virus stimulus plan as millions
of cash-strapped americans wonder if
they'll be getting any more help
from the government with federal
unemployment benefits and an eviction
protection program about to expire at
least
one signal is emerging republican
senator
lindsey graham who met with the
president on christmas day
tweeted that mr trump seems even more
convinced that stimulus payments should
be more than
tripled to two thousand dollars per
person
the president is spending the holidays
at his florida resort paula reed is
traveling with the president and she's
there
good morning paula good morning trica
well one thing americans did not get for
christmas yesterday was any clarity on
this economic relief
even as some unemployment benefits are
set to run out
this weekend now this week congress
passed this bill but president trump has
threatened to veto it unless payments
those checks that individuals and
families receive
unless those are tripled now the massive
5
500 page bill was actually flown down
here to florida
for the president to sign if he wants
cbs news has confirmed
that the president has physically
received the bill but the white house
has not given
any indication won't provide any details
about what the president intends to do
one clue we have though is from a tweet
yesterday from the president
where he asked quote why would
politicians not want to give people two
thousand dollars
rather than only six hundred it wasn't
their fault it was
china give our people the money
but the big obstacle to giving people
larger checks has been
republicans house republicans blocked an
effort by democrats this week to
increase
those stimulus payments and after that
attempt failed
members of both parties were calling for
the president to just
sign the bill as is now while the
president has been here in florida
he says that he has been in meetings and
taking calls but they have provided
no details about who the president is
talking to
what they're talking about whether
they're working on any kind of strategy
the only time we've actually seen the
president publicly
has been a few brief glimpses of his
motorcade as it has pulled into his golf
club
down here the president has ten days
from the time he receives this bill
to sign it but the first big deadline
comes on monday when government funding
runs out setting up potentially the
third government shutdown of the trump
administration
and elaine paula this week the president
vetoed a 740 billion
defense bill on monday congress could
vote to override his veto but
it will require congressional
republicans to defy the president
what can we expect to see
well this is so interesting elaine
because it really does set up this test
of whether certain gop members are
indeed willing to defy the president
now congress passed this bill with veto
proof majorities in both
chambers but the president has signaled
for weeks that he was going to veto it
unless lawmakers
used the bill to curtail the protections
that social media companies have
now also the president has said that he
objects to legislation
in the bill that would require some
military bases to be renamed if they
were named after
confederate leaders but some republicans
have already said
that even if they voted for this bill
they will not vote
to override the president so it's not
clear
if lawmakers will be able to get around
the president's veto
elaine all right paula thank you